second on the top I'll do it clearly I
don't listen to direction
that's literally our one no I'm
literally like what's a ginger Jenga get
off the stage I'm beginning
Django giant Jenga I'm gonna go here ooh
these are sticky guys it's like human is
this human dares what's the humidity
nation somebody check them out at the
end
oh my god okay charades
ready yeah two words first word two
syllables two syllables oh no just
kidding
second words that get word when while
syllable tall house roof pyramid shrine
pand Tinsel's tree Christmas tree bingo
got the whole fair nailed it yeah I'm
sort of like going downstairs I was
trying to do the leg gotcha I got me
some good okay go that one says WTF it
sure does yeah that's good sure does job
okay guys real cute envelope let's gets
creative they can't be compliments yes
it'll would drive you crazy better get
honorable no neither wear deodorant they
both recruit they both reek I just I
can't live up to their amazing parenting
and food standards no it's true
now just feel like a mess of what if I
just start bawling right I would yes
very smart March in New York we've got
an engineer guess my first name is
Eileen that was awesome I also um I know
what it is because it used to be one of
my World of Warcraft characters okay
aleem Jonesy Valentin and worst moments
in history like this the truth first of
all I hate the word celebrity but I
suppose it would have been we hate
celebrity worse than the word influencer
I hate it makes my spine like oboe so
with a craziest celebrity encounter that
I've ever had was I have a real big
crush on Riz Ahmed and my husband knows
it's like my wingman and we met him at
the Golden Globes last year and I was
nervous and my husband was like come up
and meet him and I was like no thank you
I was like this he goes I went I just
want you to meet my wife rizz this is
Kristin she finds you very attractive
and then it was like crickets and then
you could tell by the look on his face
that he was like is this a trap are they
inviting me into some weird sort of
situation after the Globes and it would
tell how uncomfortable we made him and
so that was probably the craziest and
then I kind of just walked away I was
like and that was it that's craziest at
the end for a living God I know really
whoo-hoo took naps did you take naps all
the time how dare you look in the
opposite side of you you are the best
would you ask this question anytime
honest to God if you told me I could go
to bed on the ground right now for 18
minutes sleep no probably time oh wait
what's this what's this cave oh I was
just gonna say if you put it on the
table
thank you literally r1 I gave birth I'm
on the knife oh yes yeah okay this is
gonna be this is troubling because I
might go down low I might just go for
the one that Wiggles yes oh yeah
somebody turned the humidity down
somebody did it thank you
yeah I was a very late bloomer my first
kiss was on my porch
with a guy named Alex who was like a
complete stoner but also sixteen and I
think I just did it cuz like everybody
else was doing it but I did at that
point really want to kiss someone but I
didn't really know like what that meant
I had like a little Jennifer convertible
chair in my room and we like watched a
movie right and then yeah I like walked
him to my door and then as he was
leaving there just like I guess it was a
French kiss that was a French consumer
here it was one of these no but I'm
definitely smoking weed somewhere I Love
Lucy these are good that Wonder Woman
something that jiggles you're gonna pull
it you don't wanna pull it you don't
wanna pull it pull it out yeah pull it
out ladies I would say the nice list is
I mean birth clearly gave birth it's my
one good and naughty list for looking
this good after giving birth so I'm just
putting it right back on there and I
would say nice list just hearing about
your hurricane or my experience I think
maybe I was so she was like get out of
Florida right now and then some more
like wheelchair race I mean I did for
morale oh we want that one does that one
feel good to you okay no gifts are bad
odd I should agree with you I have never
gotten a bad gift yeah you haven't not
like a bat not little egg if I'm like
that's a bad gift no because it's always
good intent may have been lucky enough
um or that no one's ever giving me like
an ill intended gift yeah oh okay
well I'm feeling frisky so I'm going low
don't look like downtown guys this one
said where is Ahmed is in your dressing
room
[Music]
I'm usually the cute cop that's easily
manipulated I'm a pushover cop I'm a cop
three times in the first two times I
tell you no begging but you go for the
third you're gonna get it that's kind of
cop I am okay oh yeah oh yeah that was
just I need doing it for me take your
shoes off
[Music]
Oh guys you guys oh my god you guys
we're gonna put him down one two three
I'm not listen I'm not helping I
literally just standing here getting a
good walk I was like maybe five six
seven around there and I was like hey
man from school I was like what
somebody's at school told me Santa
wasn't real and my brother who six years
older than I was like listen I'll tell
you the truth and I was like yeah I'm
ready and he was like Santa doesn't ride
a sleigh clearly that doesn't exist
because we all know people don't fly he
flies a plane that's how he gets around
all in one night and that's not me in
another year it bought me a whole year
of thinking that saying existed what my
brother told me that Santa doesn't write
a slide but instead spoil alert rides on
a plane and I was like that makes sense
I was like 12 thank you I'm like I don't
have to go worth less than these you
have to get your hands on this huh okay
I know I feel like a ginger doula tend
to do as I feel sexually through it just
breathe just breathe you didn't know
where Jacob Rose did you guys look what
we're doing because maybe that would all
starts as well this is the most sexual
don't breathe and down I told I said
that his birthday was a different day I
was working out of town he was like
three guys he really we didn't know he
didn't know and I was like happy I had
to leave on his eggs little birthday
anyway what about the bomb I'm lifting
all the time every year every all the
time I usually live in everything in
anything every gift everything my
grandmother's ever give that's me I'm
doing to something that's dangerous okay
all right that's real dangerous that's
all you got
I'm gonna see that because I know
there's yes fixture but you plan the
dance
good good game you're gonna get really
good game I'm really about